[Applause]
in a decade of minor league hockey brock
montgomery scored plenty of goals and
through his fair share of punches too
and there's going to be a fight
montgomery off the ice he practiced yoga
and mindfulness to deal with the stress
playing professionally in the
netherlands he met claire de hasse
traveling together just before the
pandemic claire saw a job ad caretakers
wanted for summer cottages on a small
irish island i showed brock immediately
and then he said
where can we apply and we applied the
next day the only problem thousands of
others did too and then covered 19 hit
stranding them on an indonesian island
it was kind of surreal because we had
the island
to ourselves for a little bit there
something that'll never happen again
they stayed there for months and
volunteered before heading to canada and
back to europe this year a few weeks ago
we got a message from them
if we were still in and we immediately
said yes now as restrictions ease for
the rest of us brock and claire are
going into self-imposed exile off the
grid for six months so there'll be a
solar panel that gives us enough to
charge our phone and our laptop and
stuff like that um and they bring food
to us every day although solar panels
may only go so far in an irish summer
claire's always joking that we're not
made of sugar she's dutch so yeah so
we're expecting we're expecting some
rain seclusion has perhaps one major
challenge for any couple
it's like we're not we're not leaving so
we just have to get used to it and enjoy
not kill each other
that mindfulness training may come in
very handy and if brock ever feels
homesick he can just squint into the
atlantic sunset over the next island
over known here as the sleeping giant
next stop canada redmond shannon global
news london